today on the matt wall show trump is
finally sending
a surge of federal law enforcement
officers into our
cities where violence and anarchy has
been raining of course for
months and longer uh better late than
never we'll talk about that also five
headlines including the blm supporter
who's pictured
kneeling on the neck of a toddler
apparently in support of black lives
matter and in our daily cancellation we
will cancel
the virtual fans that fox is
planning to use during their sports
broadcast this uh this
this coming season uh it sounds like a
horrible and dystopian idea it's almost
hard to believe
we'll talk about that also coming up we
begin here the riots in portland
uh continued for another night last
night
uh here i'll just play a few clips just
so you get a taste of it here are some
of the peaceful protesters in
battle armor and gas masks throwing
projectiles
very peacefully of course at police
[Music]
yes a lot of peace a lot of peace love
and harmony there and here they are
trying to set
fire to the federal court building
[Music]
and then and then and then here they are
um trying to set fire to the
federal court building but then
accidentally setting one of their own
antifa comrades on fire instead
oh man you hate to see that don't you
you really
can we see that again let's watch that
one more time
geez that's terrible that is just
terrible i'm not laughing i it's it's
not i'm not smiling about that i'm i'm
these this is a smile of sorrow or i
just really
you know i hope that guy wasn't hurt um
anyway now the thing is
if if you'd if you'd been living you
know in a cave for the last several
months which
probably is not a bad idea you'd
probably go back into the cave if that's
where you've been in fact
are there any caves nearby that i could
that i could rent out do you have any
do you have any neighboring caves that
are open um but if you had been in a in
a cave
and you you emerged and you saw the the
peaceful protests in portland or in
seattle and by the way here are some of
the
here's some of the aftermath of the
peaceful demonstrations in seattle two
nights ago look at this
um just super peaceful stuff right there
i've never seen really
so many pieces of things all in one
place but
if you saw all of this you probably
think to yourself
wow these people are really mad these
these are
really mad people something terrible
must have happened to them or to
somebody uh
i mean they must have suffered some
sort of horrific injustice imagine
you're shocked though when you discover
that nothing happened to these people at
all they suffered no
injustice of any kind
everything was fine in their lives
everything was perfect
these are probably not just that these
these people are not oppressed
these are probably the least oppressed
people on earth
actually you would find out there is no
reason for any of this
well no justified reason anyway no no
no moral reason no no sane reason no
coherent reason i should say unless
we're really going to pretend that this
is still about george floyd i know that
you might say oh something terrible did
happen george floyd yeah i was
if if we're really going to still
pretend two months later
riots in the street they're still
rioting because they're mad
about george floyd um
but of course we know that's that's not
the case there's there's there's no
and really when you look at the footage
you don't even see that many
signs anymore with george floyd justice
for flooding
maybe some people still have the but
they're they're
i don't even think they're pretending to
be mad about that anymore
and if you were to ask them what are you
protesting about
as people have asked them they can't
give much of a coherent reason
now donald trump in response to all of
this held a press conference
that was well it was better late than
never anyway here's what he had to say
politicians refuse to do what is
necessary
to secure their neighborhood and to
secure their city
every american no matter their income
their race or their zip code should be
able to walk their city streets
free from violence and free from fear
for this reason today i am announcing
that the department of justice will
immediately surge
federal law enforcement to the city of
chicago
the fbi atf dea
u.s marshals service and homeland
security will together be sending
hundreds of skilled law enforcement
officers to chicago
to help drive down violent crime
and murderers and violent criminals are
breaking a wide range of federal laws
we have that it's as wide as it can be
we will find them arrest them and
prosecute them
they will be in jail for many years to
come we'll talk about what you just
heard there in in a second but first
the show today brought to you by rad
power bikes
uh you know using a an electric bike for
getting out of the house and getting
around
is i mean it's really the best of both
worlds because you're out on a bike
but you're not getting all sweaty and
everything you can go and go a lot
further
uh it takes less effort and energy so
whatever you're looking for if you want
a way to commute if you want to get
around town
if you just want to get out in nature uh
whether this is a
you know just a ride for pleasure or
because you want to get from point a to
point b whatever it is
you've got to try rad power bikes it's a
cross between a traditional bike and a
moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would you
go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling
so you get out and about without getting
all sweaty and they're great for
commuting
they're great for getting out on the
trail they're great for hauling
groceries
um for transporting your kids on the
back if you want to i mean whatever you
want to do unlike other e-bikes they're
actually affordable plus
to show appreciation for those that
serve us rad power bucks is offering 100
off all e-bike purchases for the for
active and ex-military
first responders teachers and students
uh do you know someone who loves being
active outdoors well tell them about rad
power bikes
if you're really generous you could get
them a rad power bike as a gift
um it's just you know for me i'm a huge
fan of products that are
practical but also fun that's that's the
best combination
and rad power bikes speaking of
practical offers flexible financing for
as low as zero percent apr
and right now as a limited time offer
you can get a free accessory with the
purchase of a bike that's right
get a free gift of up to 100 in value
and free shipping to the lower 48 states
to get this special offer text the word
bike to 64 000 that's bike to 64 000.
bike bike to 64
000. okay you just heard from
donald trump he's going to send federal
uh law enforcement agents into chicago
other cities as well cities that have
been torn apart by violence and anarchy
now i think he should have done this 50
days ago but at least it's happening now
a couple of notes here the left of
course is having
conniption fits about this but they're
in a constant state of connection so
it's hard to even discern one thing from
another
uh we just add this into the list of of
things they're panicking over
and and who really cares what they think
anymore
but the claim is being made that federal
law enforcement
have no place here um they have no
authority to come in
and act whether it's in portland or
chicago or anywhere else now
that's obviously not true and and i do
wonder
like the people saying that federal law
enforcement has no play what do you
think we have federal law enforcement
for like what what do you think they're
supposed to do
we have many federal law enforcement
agencies
what what do you imagine their role is
you think they have no role when there's
violence in anarchy across the country
and federal buildings are being burned
you know burned and attacked you think
they have no role at all in that
they're supposed to just sit back well
they have been sitting back up until now
for the most part um federal law
enforcement
now i'm no legal expert but here's what
i know federal law enforcement deals
with
federal crime that's not too hard to
understand
you just saw a federal building being
set on fire
setting a federal building on fire folks
is a federal crime
that's why the feds are in portland
that's why they happen to be stationed
around federal buildings
because they're trying to protect those
buildings when antifa
cries about the feds being there here's
what they're crying about let's
understand
they're crying that they aren't being
allowed to burn down a federal building
that's the oppression i said before that
nothing's happening to them they're not
being oppressed
um i guess i'm wrong they they are being
prevented from burning down a federal
building
that's the oppression they're suffering
is that they're not being allowed to
burn down effect
they can build here's here's the other
thing they can burn down any other
building they want
it seems like you could burn down a
local police station you can burn down
you know you want to burn down a cvs you
want to burn down um
whatever you know a walmart a target
really any private business any um local
government building you're allowed to
burn down
apparently you shouldn't be but
apparently those are the rules now
the only line that's been drawn is okay
you can't burn down the federal
buildings
that we're gonna draw the line you can't
do that
and antifa says oh my god i'm being
oppressed
we can't burn down the federal buildings
um this is unspeakable tyranny for them
they claim
and there are great many people in media
who are taking that
seriously and expect us to take it
seriously
but federal crimes are not just limited
to destruction
or attempted destruction of federal
property
domestic terrorism is a federal crime
here's how the fbi defines domestic
terrorism
here's what it says on the website
violent crime
or criminal acts committed by
individuals and or groups to further
ideological goals stemming from domestic
influences such as those of a political
religious social racial or environmental
nature well
there you go okay that's antifa they are
a domestic terror group by definition
and as such federal law enforcement has
every right and every reason
and every responsibility to deal with
them
and deal a lot more harshly with them
than they have by now
up to this point um black lives matter
is also by this definition a domestic
terror group
black lives matter is a domestic terror
group they because
they use violence to further domestic
political goals that is domestic
terrorism
again literally by definition that is
domestic terrorism
so all this handwringing about the
federal involvement uh the alleged
unconstitutional nature of
the federal involvement here from people
who otherwise hate the constitution
and and and condemn it as a racist white
supremacist
screed is absurd and should just be
ignored
second point to be made here um
to those on the right because the
criticisms of federal involvement
and trump's press conference yesterday
come you know from the right and the
left uh mostly from the left but there's
been some on the right who have said
who are worried about the optics of of
trump sending
federal um agents
in and uh they think we should just let
you know leave these cities to their own
devices
and let the mayors deal with it
and if the city doesn't want to take
care of itself that's their problem
no i i don't think that's the right
approach and i've been saying this for
months that's not the right approach
at all for several reasons number one
you know when you say oh let it's the
city's problem let them handle it
um like you know it's like they they've
got a dose of their own medicine kind of
thing
what you're really saying is let the bad
guys win
because that that's not a punishment
when you take that approach take a
hands-off approach
that's a punishment to the law-abiding
citizens of those cities
of which there are still many um
who didn't do anything or the only thing
they did wrong was living in a city
which they might be
which i i think at this point if you're
trying to decide where to move you're
insane if you move into a city but
people already in the city
they might they live there because
that's where their job is or there are a
lot of reasons why a person might live
in the city
um so all you're doing is penalizing
them for the for the criminals and the
anarchists
and the domestic terrorists this is this
is great this isn't a punishment to them
to let them do it no it's not justice to
let the bad guys win we can't do that
and uh so even if i were to to agree
that
optically it's not the best well
there are considerations beyond optics
especially when you're the president or
at least there should be
and one consideration is justice and
protecting the innocent that's what the
government is supposed to do
but even optics i just don't buy that
there's any problem with optics here
um it's you want to talk about bad
optics
having anarchists in cities across the
country destroying at will
on a whim committing whatever crime they
want for weeks on end
that makes you look weak you want to
talk about bad optics there you go
right there
this is what this this this is what
people want to see this is what
normal sane law-abiding americans who
are not far leftists
i already covered that by saying sane
this is what they want to see
so i think it's the right thing and i
hope that trump actually uh you know
follows through because the other
the other thing is that we've we've seen
trump announce many things in press
conferences that don't actually happen
um and so i hope that this that this
actually happens
we know it's happening in portland i
think it needs to happen
uh you know on on a wider scale than
that as was said yesterday
all right let's go to our um
five headlines you know before we get
there
a lot going on we're going to talk about
some of the some of the other stuff
going on in headline in the headline
section
if you want to keep up on everything
happening in the world we've been
telling you about this reader's past
well you got you got to do it you got to
get the reader's pass reader reader's
past member you get access to
all of our exclusive op-eds um from not
just your podcast host but also
uh the guest writers and from our great
daily wire reporters
it's only three dollars a month but
we're knocking that down knocking two
dollars off
and you get your first month for 99
cents now so you get access to our
mobile app
you can receive push notifications
breaking news special content
as well as join the community of daily
wire members who are actively commenting
and discussing our content with each
other
you get all of that if you go to
dailywire.com subscribe
and join today all right now we'll get
to five headlines
[Music]
number one joe biden made some waves
yesterday when he got out of bed for the
first time in four weeks and did an
interview and during this interview he
accused trump of being not only
a racist but the first racist president
we've ever had watch
no sitting president has ever done this
never
never never no republican president has
done this no democratic president
we've have racist and they've existed
they've tried to get elected president
he's the first one that has
now i actually love this from biden and
i'll tell you why it's com
it completely undermines the effort of
the anti-statute squad
they've torn down jefferson washington
lincoln
roosevelt others all on the basis
that those guys were racist and now
biden is saying no none of them were
raises trump is the first racist one
which is great it's it's obviously
nonsensical and not true but it's great
also to note here we're numb to this
by now but you know and some of you
young whippersnappers might not
realize this but it used to be
a big deal to call a president racist
that used to be something that you
didn't just go around saying
um even recently kanye west
15 years ago relatively recently um
called george bush a racist and it was a
huge controversy
people were talking about it for weeks
after that people still talk about it
that's how big of a deal it was and now
the dems call trump a racist as a matter
of course
every day they call them that they wake
up in the morning and that's the first
thing they say they just wake up and
trump's a racist all right let's start
today it's it's it's compulsive it's a
compulsion now for them and the effect
of course is that the word has lost all
meaning so
ironically the men like bush who were
merely called racist
uh you know once every few months
were more successfully painted as racist
because at least back then the word race
has still had some sort of meaning
number two a couple of pictures i want
to show you here first look at this
mug shot that that right there you're
looking at that's a scumbag named isaiah
jackson um
i want you to take a a good look at this
monstrous
piece of dirt there he is and
so you don't think i'm being harsh in my
description of him
here's the picture that got him arrested
take a look at that
there he is kneeling on a toddler's neck
uh with the caption blm
now actually says blm now mother effer
and that apparently is his girlfriend's
child the mother the girlfriend
allegedly was unaware that this picture
was being taken she wasn't she was in
the house but didn't know
about this supposedly i find that hard
to believe personally i mean the child
was in distress
clearly obviously screaming because he
was in pain and he was terrified
did she not realize that did she not
hear it did she not wonder why her son
was screaming in fear while alone in the
room with her dirtbag scumbag
boyfriend i don't know
whether she was aware or not this guy's
going to jail uh
and and and hopefully now there are two
other people involved there there's
someone taking a picture
and there's also someone holding the
child's arms back and i think at this
point police still aren't sure who those
other people are i you know
again you have to wonder whether it was
the mother
but uh you know the police say it wasn't
okay
all i'll say is i i can only hope that
some of the other prisoners
in whatever prison he goes to see that
picture
and decide that they want to have a good
long talk with mr jackson about it
that's all just a talk that's all i
would be hoping for
just just the kind of talk that
prisoners have with other prisoners who
harm children in that way um maybe
that'll
help them see see the light in more ways
than one
three now uh this is kind of redundant
at this point but let me play you
another clip this is congressman bobby
rush of illinois
being interviewed by talk radio host joe
madison and reacting to trump's plans to
send troops or
not troops so i'm already i'm already
using their
they've got me now uh they've
conditioned me to call
to descend in federal law enforcement to
chicago
now russia's 73 years old
he's a 14-term congressman okay he's
been in congress for 14 terms
and if you want to know whether rush was
re-elected 14 times because he's just
that sharp and brilliant and competent
well listen to this i think that when
trump is ready to sign the new
uh uh my my friend i think that
trump is really trying to instigate a
race war
he wants to have a reaction everybody
means
that ain't going to accept that i mean
they're not
he if he sends them in he better not
send them into
uh the the south side
west side you might have seen them uh
send them over to the
uh gentile north side because their name
coming
then i'm not advocating that but i
didn't know
that that's what trump's game plan trump
wants
to instigate a race war he want to help
black people so he didn't rise up and
say
i'm the real uh uh red
red wizard and i'm the president
he re-elected me that's what he's trying
to do he's trying to
paint uh playing to the uh interference
to any uh racial animals that exist
among certain white people and he would
do everything and anything
to uh do that because he wants to meet
re-elected and all folks now i did you a
favor there i only played you a fraction
of russia's babbling answer uh he
actually begins by saying
he he's asked this all started because
he was asked
by the the host what does he think about
this plan
and he he uh what you what i just played
there was about three minutes into his
answer
and the first three minutes were just as
incomprehensible as what you just heard
but he does begin by calling the federal
law enforcement
officers armed bandits he actually calls
them bandits
and then another point he calls them
militia and then he transitions into
trump wanting a race war and trump being
the grand wizard of the kkk
yeah it's trump who wants a race war
right it's not it's donald trump is the
one trying to start a race war
it's not the people like bobby rush
and any other democrat and people in the
media
who are going out there telling uh you
know black americans that
that that white cops are on on the hunt
on the prowl trying to execute them in
the street
just for the crime of being black no
that that's not what's starting a race
war is it
telling this lie of systemic racism i
mean from from
relentlessly continuously
telling people that uh that you know
that
that white people are engaged in some
sort of conspiracy to discriminate and
oppress them
that they're in a systemically racist
country it's always been racist
it's it's inherently racist everything
about it is racist
and again they're being they're being
hunted and executed by racist white cops
no that's not the thing that's going to
start a race war not at all no it's
donald trump sending in law enforcement
officers to stop people from burning
down federal buildings
number four we know that uh teen vogue
has some
wacky far left stuff here's the latest
from them headline
joe rogan is spreading transphobic hate
speech and it's putting lives in danger
let me read a little bit from this it
says
joe rogan is one of the biggest figures
in podcasting his show the joe rogan
experience
consists of lengthy often rambling
interviews with a diverse array of
athletes
academics actors entrepreneurs and more
but you could also say that rogan has
really built his audience through
selecting guests who bring their own
notoriety to the show
um blah blah blah okay
a lot of times there's it's harmless fun
and then there are the episodes which by
virtue of rogan's massive online reach
lend a veneer of credibility to some
truly dangerous prejudices
take the recent episode with guest
abigail schreier
during schreier's conversation with
rogan which she promoted her book
irreversible
damage the transgender craze seducing
our daughters um
sounds like a great book i should have
to pick that up schreier in
here's the part schreier invalidated the
lived experience of trans and non-binary
kids and teens
and made numerous dangerous entirely
unsound
false equivalencies um then it goes on
some more saying uh you know rogan is
is horrible and bigoted and then it says
which is worse to expose such bigotry to
your millions of subscribers because you
genuinely endorse it
or to have so little conviction that you
will knowingly platform hate speech
about some of the most vulnerable
persecuted young people in our society
to benefit your own
career you be the judge both are
appalling in their own way
and it goes on by the way i lied
this is not a teen vogue article this is
in men's health
yes men's health magazine a magazine
allegedly published to serve an
audience of adult males and it contains
an article
vilifying joe rogan for not believing
that females have penises
and it includes phrases like invalidated
the lived experience of trans kids and
teens
um or sorry trans and non-binary kids
and teens
i hope i didn't just invalidate their
experience by excluding them
accidentally just there now i ask you
has any heterosexual adult male ever
ever non-ironically said the phrase
invalidated the lived experience
i mean has any has any such male uh ever
even said the phrase transphobic hate
speech
so who is this article supposed to
appeal to well we know that these days
everything all things everywhere
must first and foremost serve our
leftist cultural overlords
which is why a men's magazine article
could be lifted and transplanted
into teen vogue intact and it wouldn't
seem out of place at all
and in fact i i checked it right before
i came on the air uh
it was written by philip ellis this
article in men's health
and he actually does write for teen
vogue too so that probably tells you
everything you know
um you know and admittedly i don't know
i don't know who exactly buys these
men's lifestyle magazines
um but i would
imagine that whatever the audience is
it's probably not
an audience for content like that what
do i know
five uh finally a bit of good news for
you so you don't have to worry about
this anymore
thankfully according to huffington post
producers at the hallmark channel
are in quote active negotiations to
include more lgbtq people in their
christmas
movies thank god
uh it's you know because this this is
this is a problem we'd all
spent nights worrying about lost a lot
of sleep over because you know
in fact just last year i was watching a
hallmark christmas movie with my kids
and i thought to myself are there any
non-binary trans
pansexuals in this movie
by the way spoiler there weren't not a
single one
uh it was pretty outrageous but hallmark
fortunately is solving that problem
because like i said before remember who
we must serve first and foremost
hallmark their job just like men's
health magazine
you would think their job is to serve
and provide content for
adult males no it's to serve and provide
content for
our leftist overlords and same for
hallmark you'd think that you know their
audience
christian conservative families nope not
not them
um actually six here's a little bonus
here because i enjoyed this i want to
throw this in
this is from a guy named peter thatchell
i don't know who he is or what he does
his bio says he's quote for human rights
democracy global justice and lgbti
freedom so i guess that's what he does i
answer my question here's his
here's his tweet appears to be
non-ironic i don't think this is satire
he says uk's head of state is first-born
descendant of each generation of the
all-white senior royals
black and asian people are therefore
excluded from being head of state for a
foreseeable future
this is institutional racism yes the
royal family is racist
for not being black that's the how dare
they not be black
they should have really thought about
this before they decided to not be black
you know you need to think twice
honestly a white person's choice
to be white rather than black is tacky
at best
but really peter's right is actually
racist of course we we're just gonna
ignore the fact i guess that a black
woman
did marry into the royal family
and then promptly took the prince and
left to america to become an actress
so that doesn't matter though the real
problem here is that the queen of
england is
is you know if she was black um
then we wouldn't have an issue um but
every day she decides to continue being
white
what a racist scumbag
with all due respect we're gonna move on
to our daily cancellation
um you know by the way before we do ben
shapiro has uh his new book just came
out came out july 21st so it's uh on the
shelves now how to destroy america in
three easy steps
and he must have seen the future when
he's writing this because it's it's it's
come to life all around us
unfortunately unfortunately for us um
the book covers two fundamentally
different visions of america that are
now on the table one one vision is
unifying
finds our unity in shared philosophy
culture and history the other
disintegrates our country
in the name of fundamental fundamental
change disintegrationists are also
using weapons like cancel culture to
build their whole new
world order that they're building how to
destroy america three easy steps details
how this alternate worldview has gained
so much cultural ground so quickly um
you can pick it up at amazon you can
also go to barnes noble
right now and buy a copy and i would
recommend you do that
now for our daily cancellation this is a
quick one but it's important
we're going to be canceling well i'll
just show you watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's amazing that that's real
that is that's actually real
if if you got into a time machine i had
you in a cave before let's say you're in
a time machine now
you got it to a time machine back in
october 2019
and you came here to august of 2020
which would be kind of a lame
destination for a time machine i mean
you go 10 months into the future right
you can think of anywhere else better to
go
but anyway let's say you did and
imagine emerging and seeing that
commercial
you would you'd just be utterly baffled
wouldn't you it would seem like
we became a society straight out of a
dystopian fiction novel overnight which
in fact
we did um only i guess you could say it
didn't really happen overnight
it's been happening over the course of
many decades um
there have just been some things that
have thrown some accelerant onto it
recently
uh by the way i guess if you're if
you're listening to the audio podcast
just to clue you in that was a
commercial
from fox sports advertising the fact
that they're going to have virtual fans
at all of their games starting i guess i
think it said this week
because we can't have real fans because
you know
putting 30 000 people let's say
spreading them out over a 70
000 person stadium is somehow dangerous
we can't do that so instead fox is gonna
have fake fans virtual fans
in the stands and um
they tell us we should be excited
specifically because the virtual fans
can boo
they can cheer they can even do the wave
it actually mentions all those things
virtual fans
now with booing get yours now only five
low payments of 29.99
this is a a horrendous idea on many
levels
besides it'll be totally unrealistic if
you think about it during football
season
to see fans in the stands you know in
jacksonville
that's really going to take me out of
the whole experience
why not have virtual players too at this
point why not go full dystopia here
also another problem you think about the
experience
like in philly stadiums whether it's
baseball or football
how are you going to simulate the stench
in the philly stadiums if actual
philadelphia fans aren't there
and are you gonna have virtual bottles
being thrown and that sort of thing
so there are many issues with this um
and that's why i'm canceling virtual
fans
which is probably a moot point because
my prediction would be that they're
going to do this for one week and then
stop it when they see how weird it is
and how poorly received it is by the
viewing audience
this this is are we supposed to just
i don't even i don't understand the
point are we do they expect us to forget
that there's nobody actually in the
stands
imagine how distracting that's going to
be
when you're trying to watch a game and
you see all these
polygons um surrounding the players
that's
just weird and it's cancelled i won't
allow it i disallow it
cancelled all right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
trump brings back the coronavirus
briefings democrats defend
china and the mlb gets woke plus the
mailbag check it out on the michael
knull show